[Music]
most people know cameron and tyler
winklevoss
as co-founders of facebook and early
investors in bitcoin
but what drove them to facebook and
bitcoin is actually a lifelong desire
to stand up to authority and centralized
power
and in this country where we value
freedom and independence so much
it's actually ironic how much of our
lives and how much of our information is
actually controlled by only a few
companies
so i thought it would be interesting to
talk to them about what it'll take to
break away from
authority this is a bit of optimism
cameron and tyler thanks so much for
sitting down to talk with me
firstly and i don't want to go down a
rabbit hole with this
but i am just dying to know what was
your original concept for
facebook way back in harvard and did you
ever imagine
what it would become or did you have a
glimpse of what it could become
so we at the start of our junior year
in college and one of the things that i
think drew us
there in cambridge massachusetts was
this idea that there's something like 50
different universities and colleges
it's a super cool environment and area
and probably one of the neatest academic
and idea based communities i think
in the us if not the world and
what we found as we approached our
junior year we were talking with our
friend and who became our partner at
that time divia narendra
and we were like wow we can't believe
we're already halfway through
university it's going so quickly
there's all these opportunities and we
felt like
we're running out of time and we've
barely scratched
the surface of the community where we're
at
currently or any of these other
communities nearby
and what happens is you get into your
track you get into your major
in our case we are rowers so between
those two
you have this amazing network of the
boathouse and your teammates
but you do get locked in to these paths
so we started to brainstorm is there a
technical solution to effectively
constrain time and geography
and can our fingers do the walking and
if we were to create a social network
where people could link and connect with
each other
that could be really interesting and i
think there's
two critical points here the real
innovation
the key here is we identified that
a dot edu was part of your identity
and so if you had let's say a
harvard.edu email address
there's a very high probability that you
actually go to that
institution it's sort of like your
online passport
and prior to that places like friendster
and myspace
you really didn't have an identity and
there was no control
of who was who and by using the dot edu
which could then later be expanded to a
com
of let's say a company if you said hey i
work at this company
and you registered with that email
address we could immediately
verify and authenticate that you were
who you said you were
the other thing at that time was taking
digital
photos was becoming more and more
cheaper
and commonplace so it was a lot
easier to start getting your profile in
your life
online than it would have been even a
couple of years before
i think that we felt at the time if this
works at harvard there's no real reason
why it wouldn't work
at any other college or university
in the country and that's a pretty big
number of
institutions and populations and even if
it didn't
extend upwards into the professional
20 year olds or 30 year olds at that
time this generation was going to grow
up and eventually leave school and they
would take this network
and all the affinities with them so we
felt like
that there was real scale well beyond
just
a fun project at a university but
if you said do you think that there's
going to be three billion people
on a network and people have more smart
devices and more phones than people on
the planet
i don't think we probably have quite
imagined
that all-encompassing but we knew it had
legs
the fact that you got that far as
juniors in college
that really was the trajectory of what
facebook became makes me want to
invest in anything that you're
envisioning the future
so i want to talk to you about the
changing form
of what authority looks like in our
modern day and age
the idea of who's responsible for
letting information or decisions go in
and out
the centralization or decentralization
of power
we got really fascinated with the
centralization
of authority when we found bitcoin in
2012
because it basically started to create
effectively a gold 2.0 and a
decentralized
form of money that's outside the system
it's really a new system
and there is no central authority it's
literally a system of consensus
and the more we started thinking about
the future
and really the problems today because i
think to understand
the future you have to really understand
what is broken today and i think that
when you look
at the internet it has become
more and more centralized and siloed
and effectively when you go online today
you are basically logging into one of
six or so
services whether it's facebook instagram
which really is facebook
netflix for your entertainment linkedin
and apple your itunes and that part of
your world
and so i think that when you look at
the future we see an unbundling and a
decentralization
of these different systems so that if
you do want to speak
on a social media platform there isn't
an arbiter that's a central body telling
you whether or not
you may or may not contribute or what we
would call de-platforming
so it seems to be that the
trajectory of money is going in the
opposite direction as the trajectory
of the internet so you're
promoting the decentralization of money
where the internet is becoming more
centralized
the internet started off as this utopian
vision
of everything being very open
and there's actually a computer in a
museum somewhere
in i think it's silicon valley where the
guys who started google
were basically able to download the
entire data
of the internet on a computer because it
was open
today you could never do that because
the data is siloed by
companies like google in facebook so
what started off as an open internet
you're absolutely right has turned into
this
dystopic landscape that is super
centralized in these data cartels and
the term
that has emerged is basically
surveillance capitalism
where data is this good and you
the customer are the product
have the internet companies figured
something out and
humankind left to its own devices seeks
to exert control over others and
control the gateway for selfish means i
think that
if a business is given the opportunity
to become
a monopoly they will 100
take that route the idea of absolute
authority corrupts absolutely
i think that there are conveniences
with centralized planning most people
will tend to trade off convenience they
don't want to have two social networks
you don't want to upload cat memes to
two different places
you're not going to see two tick tocks
because it tends to be winner take all
and the viral nature and effects of
these things are huge
i think the short answer is the
technology didn't exist
for the internet to evolve early on any
other way
because the general business model was
advertising revenue and so it's an
eyeball game
these networks are centrally controlled
they attract eyeballs networks have a
huge
winner-take-all effect and then
how do you make money with that with
crypto
that technological breakthrough that
bitcoin achieved
it's known as the byzantine generals
problem
it allows people around the world to
cooperate
that's the mathematics behind mining
in the cryptography people are
incentivized to be good actors
and agree on things and so fast
forwarding
now it's possible to create a facebook
or a twitter where
the people who tweet the best content
get
paid in twitter coin they get rewarded
the same way an employee of a
centralized company would get
rewarded for doing a great job so
there is a world where the users of
facebook
actually are earning the money as
opposed to
a few executives and the workforce
actually at a company
but these incentives i mean we we know
what happens inside companies right
which is when we only incentivize
individual performance
we can sometimes create behaviors that
are counter to the health of the company
because
you'll find employees stabbing each
other in the back hoarding information
as opposed to sharing information
in the worst case scenarios sales people
actually
sabotaging each other so that they can
get the bonuses
and we've seen this happen on the
internet as well with the monetization
that's been created with youtube videos
one of the most extreme cases
that i can remember and i'm sure you
know this one as well i think it was a
boyfriend and girlfriend couple
who were looking for ways to drive views
so they could make the money from
youtube
and they would do stupid tricks like so
many people do
and one of the things they did was he
held a big thick dictionary
in front of his chest and she took a
loaded gun
and fired it at his chest thinking that
the dictionary would stop the bullet
and she shot him and killed him
devastating story and basically was a
stupid stunt
simply to get more views and so
individuals it seems act
the same way as companies which is when
you incentivize me to get
an eyeball i'm gonna do the most
ridiculous and sometimes unethical
things
to get those eyeballs because it makes
me rich so
companies are run by people there seems
to be no difference whether it's a
corporate
entity or individual doing those things
right right
yeah i mean the thing is the way they're
monetizing
the way they're building the algorithms
to effectively draw people
in is not a healthy algorithm
i think you could argue that a lot of it
so's division
it goes for the most polarizing click
bait
type scenario and headlines and it's
generally pulls in more negative
sentiment
and they're addictive it's the
equivalent of mcdonald's pumping their
food full of
sodium and all kinds of garbage to just
keep people coming back and the same is
true for
the white lab coats inside these
companies
effectively building algorithms
to keep people coming back and promote
eyeballs
amazon for example it's looking at what
you've read
and making a guess based on that
but there's no real serendipity to it
it's not really browsing it's this
robotic
engine that's generating close
approximations to what you've done in
the past
what i find so fun about a bookstore is
you can
walk around and wander into a corner
that you've never been in before
and bump into something and get turned
on to a book
or an idea it's effectively random in
some ways
one of the bookstores i love in
manhattan the strand i think it's got
something like
25 miles of books they've got a section
on books that were once
banned and you find all these great
books that at one point were very
scandalous or
were being written in countries that
banned that content
those types of experiences are really
hard to find on the
internet today the serendipity and the
openness
it's really what the platform is serving
up to you
and what is really in their best
interests
i find this idea so fascinating i was
actually thinking about the other day
like i read the newspaper
obsessively and i remember when i would
have a physical newspaper i would start
on the front page obviously
and i would leaf through the newspaper
and i would read the stories that
interested me
and i would always discover something
that i didn't know would interest me
because i was just leafing through the
newspaper and the headline caught my eye
and i learned about things that i would
never ordinarily learn about
then my newspaper went digital and now
the internet companies they attempt to
give us the information they think we
want
which sounds good but all kinds of
exploration
accidents serendipity all of these words
for discovery have basically disappeared
yeah and if you boil down the people who
are actually
making those algorithms and decisions
it's very few people like
ceos sitting in enclaves and
silicon valley and basically on one
stretch of
a mile of road so it's scary how much
influence that can have and i think
that makes the case for more
decentralization
decentralization inherently is about
discovery right there's exploration
in decentralization i remember reading a
study about
well-intended citizens they hear a story
in the news
and they want to do their own research
they want to find quote unquote
the truth and so they go to google like
we all do
to do research and i think the word they
used was benghazi in this research
and what they found out was basically
the people who were left leaning
the algorithm showed them left-leaning
research
the people who were right-leaning gave
them right-leaning research
so two well-intended citizens actually
got different information
from their google searches because
google's attempting to serve up what it
thinks you want to see
when you're trying to find the
unvarnished truth and so all it does is
reinforce
the left-leaning narratives of the
right-leaning narratives and by the way
the people
who had no political leanings google
gave travel advice
yeah i mean people talk about search
engine optimization
but really what they're talking about is
google
optimization engine when you're building
your website
you are building it so that google
indexes it properly
and that you rank as high as possible
and
the difference of even one position in
the search ranking could be
the difference in a magnitude of traffic
huge
huge difference depending on the term
and how popular it is
now there's obviously been some clear
wins
with google effectively organizing the
world's
information over the better part of the
last 20 years
but we're getting to a point now where
just as you say
it's starting to move and sway in a
certain direction
and i think that as we start to
decouple that and there's other options
that creates the more democratization if
you will
and i think the publishing industry is a
great place to look at
what does centralization look like i
know you remember the time when
getting a record deal meant that you
made it or
you were likely to make it but if you
couldn't get signed by a label
forget it you have no distribution no
channel no ability to get your
music or your movies or whatever art
you're creating
out there and today it's never been
easier to self-publish
or self-broadcast if you want to upload
songs onto soundcloud
you don't have to go through the anr and
then the
record companies to get to basically the
entire world
so in some ways the democratization
of the internet has been very powerful
and
impactful but the challenge is that
the new technology companies there's few
of them
and far between and so what is that next
wave it's maybe you're publishing to a
decentralized blockchain
and nobody can really pull that content
or filter it
or censor it it's just there but it's so
early days
that people are going to effectively go
for the easy option right now
if you think of like the internet pre
the first web browsers
it was a very challenging experience
and so we're kind of in that zone where
people are starting to build
these alternatives but we need things
like that new
way to browse and access it that's easy
enough for the average consumer
i just love this idea that for
exploration and discovery to happen
there has to be decentralization
so to use your analogy of the music
industry which is it was more difficult
for us to actually go on a journey of
discovery
because anything that we found was
already vetted
by authorities by the gatekeepers the
music companies
whether they chose to give one group of
record deal or not was not based on
whether they thought it was
quote unquote good music it was where
they thought it was sellable music
right and the modern version of that is
google determines what you find
and i just find this irony that it is
hard to actually go on a journey of
exploration or even truth-finding
when there is someone or an algorithm
determined by someone that is the
ostensible gatekeeper and i'm so
fascinated by this idea these terms that
we use that make it seem
so utopian and networky and open
but as you said like we're all
desperately trying to make
our websites work for google
work for one company and even the
control facebook has i mean we see this
for example
we know that the scandal that facebook
is currently dealing with and how it
presents information
and how it's sending out you know white
supremacist information and things like
that
and are not effectively editing hate
content
and we've seen large advertisers pull
their advertising away
as a show of force and facebook in their
arrogance
scoffs and say well that's a minor part
of our income most of the income comes
from small businesses
now this becomes so interesting to me
because to your point there's only
very very few companies maybe six
companies that basically
is the internet that really we can't
influence we can't force change
the authority of the gatekeeper that is
facebook unless all of the small
businesses stop advertising on facebook
the problem is if a small business stops
advertising on facebook they could
literally put themselves out of business
because there's no other option for them
yeah and facebook's not wrong in the
sense that
they very well will be back
there is no other alternative today
so it is interesting point that we're at
where people
get really frustrated with the product
and then
there's no other place to go so they
slowly acquiesce
back to it and kind of fall into that
same habit
and i think it comes down ultimately to
incentives
one of the things that's probably
important to know about the history of
the internet
is that it was widely shaped by section
230 of the communications
decency act which was basically a law
within a larger law the
telecommunications
act i think of 96 and effectively
that immunized online services
from the content that they provided so
that they were no longer liable
for third-party content that they
effectively were like the conduit
or the platform you could say that a
25-year-old
act at the speed at which technology
moves
is likely outdated now that immunization
gave them this safe harbor where they
could create
terms and services that if they applied
in good faith
that they could effectively
self-moderate but
unless there's enough incentives the
moderation is
only going to keep up with where the
incentives are
and if customers tend to not think it's
a big deal i don't think a company is
going to
invest in thousands of people to
moderate
so human beings i mean dare i say it but
we're so damn lazy
that for us we will put up with so much
stuff that we don't like for convenience
like people are up in arms that the nsa
was collecting metadata
which is depersonalized from us in order
to try and prevent
terrorists from attacking our nation but
no one has any problem whatsoever
with our credit card companies tracking
every dollar we spend
where we spend it how we spend it
building profiles on us
with our names and our addresses and
selling all of that information to
someone else
because let's be honest a credit card on
a daily basis is way more convenient
than this amorphous threat that we face
that i don't really understand
and when i say we're okay with it yes
we're up in arms every now and then
about it to your point
but we've seen very little systemic
change because of public pressure
europe i think ahead of america in that
sense yeah
europe tends to historically
side on in favor of privacy over free
speech
and it's very american to
side more on free speech over privacy
so for instance the law that we
mentioned section 230 earlier
that immunization does not exist
in europe at the same way there is this
concept called the right to be forgotten
which effectively allows people to
be forgotten from platforms with
facebook if you
quit your account or left it actually
was still there
just didn't appear to the other users
but in europe
that is expunged so facebook is
physically forced to remove it from
their servers where if you're in the
united states
a quote-unquote shutdown account still
exists with all the content sitting
somewhere
that content you've effectively given
ownership over to
the platform it's no longer yours in the
u.s
so if you're effectively giving them the
content to make it their own
but then they're no longer responsible
for the content that they now own
i can understand that they say we're not
responsible for content if we don't own
it but for the fact that they do own it
yeah it's a really interesting thing if
you look at the first amendment
the right to freedom of speech there's
no real qualifiers in it
it's a very broad statement those rights
and if you look at article 10 of the
european convention
they do call out freedom of speech
but with all of these different
qualifiers and effectively
the european system lends a little bit
more to the collective so it's sort of
like
you have the right to free speech to the
extent that it doesn't
impact the larger group or the
collective
and you don't find that in the
constitution and i think we see that
with the pandemic in the u.s who would
have thought that
a lot of these things like wearing a
mask would become a political thing
but here we are there's a lot of folks
who say look
i'm to flex my individual rights and i
just may not want to wear a mask i've
decided that i don't want to be
a shelter-in-place order and i don't
think you have that same
resistance or individualism
in europe as they approach the virus and
a lot of this goes back
very very far and is literally at the
founding of our country
it seems that to your point from before
given the opportunity every company
would love to be a monopoly
and government to some degree can act
like a monopoly
many of the things that it does in our
lives taxation being one of them
and the banks in how they controlled
money
to some degree as an industry acted
monopolistic
and we got to the point where the hubris
became so unbearable because we realized
it was so unbalanced
and that the decisions that the
gatekeepers were making were
starting too much to be prioritizing
their interests over hours we understand
a little bit of it which we're okay with
but it became so unbalanced that we
demand a decentralized currency and this
gives rise to crypto
and so we're okay with google and
facebook and the like
tilting the balance slightly towards
themselves because we accept that
ain't nothing for free and we accept
that trade-off but at what point does
hubris of the organization start to look
like the hubris of a government
or the hubris of the banking industry
rather and we start
rejecting it and finding complete
alternatives
inside the internet outside of the
social networks are we on that path i
mean it could be 30 years away 40 years
away for all i know
but hubris seems to play a role here
these companies it's so
ingrained with them to be
winner take all i don't know how they
stop
the pandemic a lot of words came into
the
lexicon zoom was one of them and as soon
as zoom
started taking off all of a sudden when
you're in gmail you get this
encouragement to try google video and
google hangout
and i think even like facebook started
to get into the video conference game
they just couldn't help themselves this
other company that's not one of these
big monopolies started doing well and
they're like oh
we've got to like focus our sights on
there and attack
and get it so i don't think the solution
is going to come from them
it's either two ways historically it's
been
the government and anti-trust but the
thing that's interesting about the
anti-trust laws is that
these monopolies look very different
than the robber baron monopolies
because the product's free it's not like
the price gouging
or the rent seeking of a traditional
monopoly
so the laws are a little bit outdated
and they're slow to catch up but they
will
and then the second option for
correcting this
is innovation and that's why we're so
bullish on cryptocurrency because
ultimately we think that that is the
path to
build the internet we keep quoting this
law but
section 230 was created to protect
and foster a budding nascent industry
that was tiny it was compuserve it was
prodigy it was aol these were
small companies but now this industry
has become
these companies that can sway elections
so they're not the little startups that
oh no we got to protect them because
it's death by a thousand cuts
they're actually the juggernauts the
tail is now wagging the dog
i'm not sure what's more powerful these
companies
or the president of the united states
who
broadcasts on these companies but can be
shut off at any point
this whole discussion is fraught with
irony the only way to stop it is with a
gatekeeper
like facebook faces a threat from
instagram it can't compete itself so it
just buys it
it faces a threat on its messaging
service from whatsapp and sees whatsapp
is this thing that's taken the world by
storm
and so they just buy it and in both
cases the founders of instagram and the
founders of whatsapp said you have to
leave it independent whatsapp has to
remain private instagram has to remain
private but of course it didn't happen
both of them now
have been sucked into the machine to
where the founders of both those
companies quit and discussed
the only way it seems that we're going
to prevent these things happening
is when the department of justice does
step in and cut these companies up and
break them up because of anti-monopoly
but for the fact that we have an
outdated definition of monopoly to your
point
right yeah okay so obviously everybody
knows you as the winklevi you are twins
and you are
apparently mirror twins which is an
even cooler version of identical twins
is this true
like one of you is left-handed and one
of you is right-handed right
this is true yeah so i'm left-handed
cameron
and tyler's right-handed and mirror
twins is actually a real thing
a lot of people never heard of it before
they're not sure if it's
real but we can attest to that it is and
what it results from i believe an
egg effectively splitting a little bit
later in the process this is really
interesting i mean even just the way you
guys communicate
one of you is slightly more left brain
and one of you is slightly more right
brained
yeah that's totally right i mean the way
it often manifests
in how we approach a problem we may end
up coming to
very similar answers or conclusions but
the way we get there is different and i
think tyler can be
the analytical piece the altitude that
he sort of flies at
could be a little bit higher than mine
one example that i
like to joke about is when we were
studying in high school
i might just throw all my papers on the
floor and
just start studying and tyler would
spend
a lot of time organizing and you have
the most organized
most beautiful notes in the world very
very well put together but he spent some
time doing that
which took away from some of the
studying i had more of like this
papers on the ground i'm just going to
go through this and
whatever and you you could say sort of
like relatively less
organized and yet we probably pretty
much got the same exact grades
now what i think is so interesting about
it is it actually i think
is a case study for good partnerships
because you guys are exceptionally good
partners
in business because you do approach
things opposite and it makes the case
that good partnerships in business
require a nice balance of left brain and
right brain that it's not one or but one
and that make for good partnership
because
you come as a perfect person nobody's
perfectly balanced
so you need two people to create that
balance of problem solving and
perception and
perspective yeah i don't think our
partnership
or team would work if we were always
ratifying each other one of the huge
assets that we have
is trust and i trust
cameron as much as i trust myself
and i believe i i hope that he feels the
same way towards me
but effectively it's like being on a
team
with yourself you have that trust so you
can disagree
we don't always agree on everything but
we feel comfortable
safe okay to say hey i think that's
that's completely wrong what are you
crazy or whatever
and hopefully ideally a respectful way
so we come at the world from a different
way
and that's what keeps it interesting but
i don't see
cameron as like a control copy print
of myself we view ourselves as very
different
very much individuals
but very identical foundationally
on values on the things that are the
most important
and the hardest to change or identical
but a little bit above that like
preferences
were very very eclectic in a way i think
this really is the model of great
partnership
which is great partnerships whether
you're born of the same mother or not
the mobile things as you said the hard
to move things the values
those things must be identical and that
is where
trust is formed and then upon that
foundation of trust
built on values you want the diversity
of opinion and perspective you want the
left brain and the right
brain cooperating and i think so often
what ends up happening
is people get together in partnership
where they don't even think about the
values first
it's because they're both share
perspective they're both left-brainers
or both right-brainers they agree with
each other
and the trust forms for a while until
they start disagreeing
or until they start having opposing
opinions or worse they come together in
partnership because they realize they
need each other and
also neglect that foundation of values i
love how you distinguish between
the identical things or the values and
then beyond that
the mirror is what makes the great
partnership because the partnership that
you have
everything you've done and the successes
you've had from high school
through your crew team facebook the
olympics
and now your foray into crypto it's
always been
the two of you it's always been this
magical partnership
yeah and it's really interesting so we
do a lot of startup investing i think we
have almost 100 different
portfolio companies at this point and
one of the most common reasons companies
fail is not because they
fail to get product market fit it's the
founder disagreement or
a personality conflict or issue that
just sinks the boat before they even
push off from the dock
to row the race and i wonder if there's
studies out there that could identify
whether there's a trend in that
direction
i mean i've always talked about it in
terms of the why type and the how type
that that's that great partnership the
visionary and the operator
and that we've made a mistake in
corporate hierarchies where we say ceos
number one
and ceo or cfo or number two and too
many cfos because they're quote-unquote
number two
want to be in line for the big job the
number one job but it's not one and two
it's one and a
that it's actually a combination of
equals that makes the partnership work
it's not
up and down but left and right i assume
because you're brothers
that's how you operate you don't operate
as one and two you operate as one and a
that's right and i think on the surface
i think a lot of people
might just assume as tyler is sort of
joking before that we're carbon copies
and not only that would that be
painfully boring
to hang out with someone who is the same
person for
that many decades but i think that you
know it offers this ability to
be interdisciplinary and take that
different approach
because at the end of the day as you've
so aptly described
we just want to play the infinite game
and the only way i think you can do that
sustainably over a period of time
is to have a diversity of thought
and opinion and real strong
ability to have disagreement in a manner
that
produces really interesting and exciting
outcomes tyler cameron thank you so much
talking to you makes my head hurt in a
very good way
and you leave me with i think way more
questions than answers which is probably
a good thing thank you so much for
taking the time thanks simon
it's real pleasure thank you for having
us a lot of fun
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you